luis castillo who is coming off an
outstanding day 11 strikeouts he made a
mistake on a home run but it felt like
several strides forward well he really
felt good about his appearance his last
appearance
and he goes right over top of it loops
it into shallow right
the wong is aboard
line drive right at a hoppy castellanos
who makes the glove
nice play by the reds right fielder two
down castillanos makes a great recovery
see a changeup that sits right over the
middle of the plate
castellanos extending to make that over
the head grab
and there's a walk is castillo missing
inside so the brewers with two singles
and a walk they're loaded in the first
against luis castillo payoff pitch
coming
ball four and the brewers
gonna run on the board here in the
opening inning
showing good patience back-to-back walks
willie adamus steps to the plate at a
base hit yesterday in his brewers debut
and there's a fly ball and it's going to
drop into center field a base hit a
chance to score a pair vogelback coming
around he's in
two-run single for adamus and the
brewers with three on the board in the
opening inning doing some good work with
two outs a couple of hits a couple of
walks three runs in
didn't hit it all that well big fastball
in on him you can see the bat shatters
but got enough of it to dump it in front
of naked one in center
and a three spot for the brewers in the
first inning so you're right i mean the
troubles for castillo in the first
continue
there goes the bat swing at the miss
look out still photographer down the
line it's just helicoptered
right near him to make contact bradley
did not castillo gets the strikeout but
athletic trainers and other personnel
are checking on the photographer
peralta yeah he's been terrific his last
two starts we highlighted those when we
came on the air 13 innings in the last
two starts
a 1-0 record with 16 punch-outs
and in the count 1-2
and there's a strikeout to start this
sunday afternoon for freddie peralta and
a fastball up at 94. i mean freddy's
fastball anywhere between 91-92
up to 97.
and 94. top of the strike zone that he
gets his man
so yet another lead off hitter retired
for freddie
and a strikeout for castillanos how
about that from 3-0 to a punch-out
back-to-back strikeouts for peralta in
the first
and this is lifted in the air toward the
left side and foul territory yet thomas
will put it away and a one two three
inning for freddie peralta the tying run
is coming up for eugenio suarez
struck him out that's just a good slider
right there beauty 80 miles an hour
looks like it stopped in midair and then
broke away from suarez one of his better
sliders right there that was a dandy 80
miles an hour outer half and down we'll
see what he goes with now against the
shortstop
fastball there you go inning over for
the reds get the first two aboard and
peralta leads him stranded we're through
two
steve retired the side in order in the
second inning payoff pitch again and a
change up just misses good take again
yeah no kidding he's seen the baseball
well no doubt
and here's avi garcia
and
garcia with a fly ball and into right
field castiano's going back looking up
it's gone
that's how you answer when it's up and
in
you send one over the wall in right a
two-run shot for ravi garcia to make it
a five-nothing game yeah both of his
hits have come to right field
only ivy gave that one a pretty good
ride again
now brew is able to add on now it's five
to nothing
jesse winker do up in his last dozen
against milwaukee yeah he's hit nearly
500
eight homers in 11 knocked in in 12
games he kills the brewers
and he wallops that one a rocket shot to
right center
it's off the power stacks
his fifth home run of the three-game
series are you kidding me with this guy
my goodness
his bat-to-ball skills are certainly
elite his power wow
luis castillo done shogoakiyama pinch
hitting here
that is slammed to deep left center
field off the base of the wall for
akiyama
and there you go there's more damage a
two bagger for the pinch hitter akiyama
at third base as nick castiano stands in
and he shoots it on the line to left
field slams off the wall akiyama scores
and castellanos jogs in the second
a thunderous rbi double
5-2
another slider curve ball
castellanos understanding just has to
get the bad head out there not trying to
do too much then michael feliz will try
to keep it right where it is the
right-hander takes over for luis
castillo whose day is over after five
innings and five earned runs three balls
two strikes to willie adamus
and he works a walk
and that's how the sixth inning begins
it's sharply knocked down by farmer and
everybody's safe
good hard contact from urea so the
brewers have runners at first and second
with one out sean doolittle will tangle
with colton wong the 1-1 pitch
wong sends one toward the gap in right
center field that's going to get to the
wall and it's going to score a couple
as a two-run triple
for colton wong
who's now a long ball away from the
cycle and it's seven to two brewers in
the six well brewers needed that so
the move to bring doolittle in for the
lefties kind of backfires at this point
but wong able to center on this one
well he hit a rocket out there in the
right center two outs says doolittle
will face
christian yelich who's the one two to
yelich and it's sharply in the center
field and base head
wong will score
yelich with an rbi and it's eight to two
brewers they put that foot down on time
that time wow
new pitcher on the hill for
the brewers it is
alec bettinger welcome to tucker
barnhart here in the eighth inning
against alec bettinger
and a little bouncer to the right side
travis shaw with the feed out number one
catches peyton looking backwards cave
from alec bettinger for route number two
and going after the first pitch max
schrock with a fly ball at the left
center christian yelich with the catch
in a nice 1-2-3 inning for bettinger in
the eighth here's yelich rbi single from
christian in the sixth inning
and yelh with a fly ball hit deep into
right field
and it is gone christian yelich
sends one out of here
his first home run of the season and
it's a nine to two ball game yeah he's
starting to get it going
now he knew he would
he's hit the ball on the screws three
times today
a no doubter
in the right center
good day at the plate for yelich
bettinger it's the one two three eighth
looking to finish this one off this
afternoon nick castellanos is standing
in
high in the air pretty deep left center
yellidge back looks up
and it's gone
home run nick castellanos
his 12th home run of the year his third
extra base end of the day
and he seesaws back in front of winker
for the league lead and average
don't give away
an at-bat
hanging breaking ball
great swing yet again
great result and a great catch
left field stands on that home run
bettinger with a 1-2 and hit over to
colton wong
and the brewers win the game and win the
series and it will be a happy flight
home
as bettinger able to finish this one off
after the reds push across a couple of
runs here in the ninth but christian
yelich and the brew crew take two out of
three with a 9-4 win this afternoon